hello you guys so today we're going to
do an oky lost situation for a 2013 uh
E-class using uh the alel we're going to
be using the XP
400 with uh the
emulator connected to the XP
400 uh to the
alel um and we're going to be adding an
aftermarket
key
we're going to be using the two
batteries
one so it's a
eClass we're going to start by just
logging into the car the car has an
active
alarm uh so it's an OSS
situation um so anyway we not going to
know how we need to connect I always
recommend just connect to the car
through the
OBD and we're going to go to Mercedes
after we're going to do
that
um we're going to be uh going and doing
it
by smart
selection always going to be the easiest
for you guys because it's going to tell
us exactly what it is and we're going to
go for all key lost
fast and we going to be using a Gbox
just to make it
faster but sometimes on model uh it's
going to be uh no fast option you're
just going to be able to do the slow
option so as you can see on this one is
a W uh
212 and it's a model year
13 so all KOST is currently unsupported
in this uh version so the way we're
going to do that we just going to go to
the all kilos and a regular version on
vehicle
so we're just going to hit
again and now it ask us to put the blank
key so just for your recommendation uh I
know some of the keys are bad are using
the double battery ones appearance to be
working way better so it's asked us to
put it in the IR IR radi is basically
this you're going to see a infrared
inside and we're just going to hit
okay it's reading the key is making sure
the key is uh
blank so ask us if we have a password so
we don't it's an oy lost we're going to
press okay to enter the calculation
uh now it's going to ask us to um
connect the OBD and everything which we
already did so basically the OBD is here
USB to the XP 400 XP 400 as this cable
which is apb1 125 that's the emulator we
just going to place it in the ignition
and we're going to hit
begin
just going to hit
okay
okay it's told us to do everything we
did already so now it's connecting to
obtain
data keep in mind that Mercedes say is
really about luck uh when we talking so
now I wants us to put in and out the
emulator so after we did that we went
into public calculation now uh sometimes
it can take it could be a nightmare it
can take like really really long time it
really depends on your
luck uh server internet
connection uh but anyways um I have
experience that it took from 2 seconds
or like maybe 2 minutes all the way to
sometimes even like 2 hours uh rarely
but normally it will be between the 20
minutes or so I will get back to you
guys uh when I get the password and I
will show you how we
proceed so I would say about uh 20
minutes into the calculation uh we have
got the password so after you get a
password uh you just want to take a
photo of that just to keep it uh for
future reference and then we're going to
just hit
okay so the passport uh calculation is
completed we're just going to press okay
to keep
going um it's going to generate the key
file so generating a key file basically
means that it takes the Eis uh data and
the code and it's basically writing a
new key slot for this key and now we're
going to write the key uh file into the
key itself so we're basically going to
put the key into the IR we're going to
press the okay it's detecting the key
and this is the moment that it's
basically writing the
key
so it's writing a key
file and after it's going to do that we
are basically
done um so as you can see in this
chassis and the
w2000
212 the job uh is not being done with
taking the elv or anything thing you
just OBD and you go on the OBD slow and
we're just going to take the key now
we're going to put it in the
ignition and we're going to turn
it and as you can
see so we're going to add some power to
the car and we're going to
make so after hooking a battery
charger um the car started right
away uh this is how you do the job is
done